[Music]
the gold standard for VR and education
is a gentleman named Chris DD he's a
professor at Harvard and he doesn't do
goggles base VR he does desktop VR
although he's moving towards goggles we
are and what what chris has built as two
amazing experiences one called eco move
M you ve and one called River City and
his virtual learning scenarios are
organic you're moving an avatar around
and you talk to other avatars you get to
run experiments and the science content
responds to what you do its engaging and
you can play it for a long time it's a
very detailed environment to do learning
he's put it in thousands of schools you
know hundreds of thousands of students
have used this and he's got great data
showing that it works in particular what
chris has shown Chris and his colleagues
have shown is students that typically
have a hard time doing well in science
for example someone that I can't I can't
be a scientist that's not what I do
whether to to your race or your gender
or for whatever reason you don't can't
see yourself as a scientist when you're
in River City you have an avatar you're
a scientist and you're doing science and
it helps those that have a hard time
imagining that they can do science he's
got great data showing that those who
struggle typically with science
River City and he can move typically
help them the challenge now is when you
go from that type of amazing learning
content to putting the virtual reality
goggles on and that's where I've been
studying for about 15 years I've been
working in this area and it's a
challenge one of my philosophies that
should come across very clearly in this
book is you shouldn't use VR for
everything there's a lot of things that
work beautifully by the written word and
by video and you shouldn't just shove
everything into the goggles needlessly
and so what I do in my lab when I design
learning content as I think well what's
going to be uniquely awesome in VR and
it turns out things that were you
actually have to look around right so
one of the key signals that you can
decide that something doesn't deserve to
be in VR if you're watching a user and
she's just staring forward the entire
time
for five minutes and well then why are
you in VR that should just be a high-res
screen right in front of you and you can
have more pixels what I've been doing
for the last few years is trying to
really understand what types of learning
and learning transfer is uniquely suited
for virtual reality when I began this
learning research I just assumed that
the immersive aspects of VR was going to
automatically cause a gain and learning
and we're finding it's more nuanced than
that
[Music]
you